peu
la princesse margaret et lord snowdon
son époux plus connu sous le nom de tony
n'ont pas déçu l'angleterre ce matin là
la foule stationner devant clarence
house et les cameramen avaient ajusté
leurs téléobjectifs pour le film est
d'ailleurs que deux fenêtres
des fenêtres derrière lesquelles se
déroulait un événement de première
importance un nouveau vicomte venait de
naître à l'angleterre aux accents
débonnaire de la musique de la gare fils
de la princesse margaret
le vicomte linley times et le cinquième
dans l'ordre de succession au trône
quant à
[Musique]
alger comme le reste de l'algérie
attendait dans l'anxiété le 1er novembre
dont le fln avait décidé de faire une
journée de manifestations on était allé
avec un jour d'avancé se recueillir sur
les tombes des disparus karl et être ce
7e anniversaire de l'insurrection aux
mappeurs la kasbah présenter des rues
bible seulement animé par la marge d'une
patrouille
l'effectif du service d'ordre à alger
avait été porté à 35 millions si bien
que les portages une fois formés en ont
été réduits à tourner en rond dans les
quartiers fermés cortège composé
d'ailleurs en majeure partie de femmes
d'enfants et de jeunes gens
partout la possibilité de heurts entre
manifestants et européens avaient été
évitées et les défilés exhibant les
couleurs fln se sont essoufflés dans la
matinée pour disparaître dans l'après
midi
à diar el mahçoul les premiers
manifestants apparaissait à 7h30
plusieurs centaines qu'ils allaient
tourner en rond dans la cité
aux portes les blindés fermer la route à
toute tentative d'étendre les
manifestations dans toute l'algérie ce
1er novembre devait toutefois se solder
par 77 morts et 140 blessés mais à alger
comme dans les autres grandes villes
d'algérie l'affrontement entre les deux
communautés a été évité
la capitale du honduras britannique
belize n'existe plus ou à peu près des
rues encore noyé sous les eaux de rares
habitations encore partiellement debout
des gens hagards c'est le spectacle
qu'offre une cité de 30000 habitants
après le passage de l'ouragan ratti
pillage menace d'épidémie n'ont fait
qu'accroître une situation beaucoup plus
désastreuse que les premières
informations erronées ou mensongère ne
l'avait laissé imaginer
l'évacuation annoncé n'ayant pas eu lieu
on compterait un grand nombre de morts
belize en effet aurait été détruite à
75%
[Applaudissements]
grâce à 25000 habitants à l'intérieur un
million ou dehors c'est cela la corse du
moins selon les corses eux mêmes et il
est de fait que les corses forme de
véritables colonies une sorte d'action
ne prétend aussi qu'en france le
policier est corse et l'adjudant et le
douanier et le gardien de prison et tant
d'autres fonctionnaient il y à du faux
et du vrai tous ces corses ne restent
pas isolé ils se voient se retrouvent
restent unis en dépit des différences de
situations racontent les mêmes histoires
et font les mêmes gestes
voilà et puis à l'heure de la retraite
il se retrouve au pays devant les mêmes
vert avec les mêmes histoires et les
mêmes silence
au soir de leur vie ils ont retrouvé ce
qu'ils n'ont jamais oublié leurs
vieilles pierres et leurs vieilles rues
ce décor tracé à grands traits durs d'un
pays qui n'a rien à exporter que ses
enfants ils retrouvent leur cimetière
car un bon corse ne peut bien dormir que
dans sa terre de corse au milieu des
noms qui ne s'évadent jamais ils
retrouvent leur mât qui leur ferait leur
montagne ses paysages qui n'ont à offrir
que leur beauté comment ici gagner sa
vie laperne nourrit que de maigres
troupeaux et les oliviers qu'on s'est
forcé de cultiver en terrasse ne paye
pas l'effort qu'ils exigent quant à
l'industrie at il vu celui-là une seule
cheminées des usines dans le ciel de son
île il a vu le ramassage des châtaignes
rien d'agricole et rien d'un nul il faut
faire venir les trois cinquièmes de ce
qui sert à la vie grevé bien entendu des
frais supplémentaires de transport
retour à vide compris puisqu'il n'ya
rien à exporter ce qui pèse sur les prix
on a pu rire de cette prime d'insularité
demandé par les corses mais distille ne
sommes nous pas en france
qui hier aurait tenté ici une aventure
industrielle ou commerciale
la ville de sartène une sous préfecture
n'a même pas de gare cas unique en
france
aucune voie ferrée ni conduit et la
vieille ville peut bien souhaité la
bienvenue à ses visiteurs il dit
débarqueront pas par train entier
certaines est un exemple extrême mais
les chemins de fer sont rares et il faut
d'un rendement suffisant on les a même
condamné ce qui a suscité des
protestations véhémentes la corse demain
pourrait être le seul département
français à ignorer le chemin de fer
quant à la route trop souvent resserré
elle se perd en et andres dans les
cantons perdus réseau parcimonieux elle
joint les villes mais par des fils si
ténue on dirait que la corse a été
oubliée pendant des décades de progrès
matériel comme elle l'avait été par des
siècles d'isolement on dirait qu'elle se
contente d'être avec ses paysages qu'ils
peuvent compter parmi les plus beaux du
monde une patrie pour petits retraités
on dirait qu'elle a toutes épuisées avec
le souvenir dans lequel ajaccio s'endort
chaque soir depuis un siècle celui d'un
petit lieutenant d'artillerie
mais il faut revoir ce problème à la
lumière d'aujourd'hui
ah ah
les caprices de la nature qui laisse
faute de pluie des régions dépérir de
ses chasses quand d'autres souffrent
d'inondations sont peut-être sur le
point d'être corrigés c'est dans cette
perspective en tout cas que se situe
l'expérience de lannemezan où le
professeur d'essence a installé son
météo tron l'appareil a fabriqué les
nuages le métier autres ont une centaine
de brûlures reliés par 700 mètres de
tuyaux à des réservoirs contenant trois
tomes de gasoil en somme le modèle géant
du dispositif employés dans les
chaudières à mazout
l'allumage évidemment est un peu plus
compliqué et c'est tout mais l'histoire
ne s'arrête pas là une énorme source de
chaleur se trouvent ainsi créée elle va
amorcer le processus de formation d'un
cumulus qui soit dit en passant n'aura
rien à voir avec les fumées parasites
dégagée par la combustion
l'air surchauffé aspirant l'air humide
ambiant à 20 km à la ronde va s'élever à
100 ou 200 kilomètres à l'heure
jusqu'aux zones d'air froid et sec ou va
s'opérer la condensation qui fera naître
un cumulus
désormais donc un cumulus fenêtre là où
l'homme en aura décidé c'est là la
révolution apportée par les expériences
de lannemezan où des radars spéciaux
permettent de suivre la formation du
nuage il suffit alors d'une projection
dieu dur d'argent sur ce nuage pour le
faire tomber rampe lui
la première étape d expérience s'est
ainsi révélé concluant le mettais autres
on a réussi à remplacer la nature ou
plutôt à lui forcer la main demain
l'homme de science pourra laisser la
place aux faiseurs de pluie et il sera
enfin possible de produire à volonté à
la terre la plus sèche sa part
d'humidité et de fertilité
la tinée beaucoup du combat de deux des
meilleurs poids moyens français marcel
picot culotte à parements blancs et
hippolyte annexes adversaire d'un soir
au palais des sports ap ap c'est un
match sans étincelle compte assister les
6000 spectateurs parisiens et pourtant
pigou et annexes sont les deux poids
moyens français les plus spectaculaires
ce qui attire la grande foule
à vrai dire le spectacle était surtout
dans la salle où se trouvaient mais les
joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football et vedette de cinéma
hippolyte annexes et plus brouillon
qu'efficace cependant son dynamisme fini
par être payant trois fois pigou va à
terre au cours du huitième round
lorsque pigou se reprend il est beaucoup
trop tard et c'est très justement
canucks remportent ce combat
leur a sans doute beaucoup plus de mal
devant son futur adversaire ray sugar
robinson l'inusable quadragénaire
nous aussi nous avons des arguments à
faire valoir dans les concours de beauté
et nous ne manquons pas totalement
d'éloquence à preuve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours sensible à de tels
arguments
mais
[Musique]
alors monsieur ne soyez pas jaloux
la boue laisse rêveur
ah ah
enfin un connaisseur
et bien c'est comme cela que l'on
devient monsieur europe 1961 ne vous en
déplaise
[Musique]